all right opening bit opening bit
opening bid with a new set the mic on
the mics totally on sorry I just really
like this movie so I want to be very I
had a good time Kingsman the Secret
Service Entertainment that is the key
word to this film like it has one goal
to entertain you and it sets out to do
just that and it completely succeeds
super fast paced hyper stylized violent
it's really funny it's unique it's also
has really like self-aware humor it's
just one hell of a good time really got
to give like kudos to this is me giving
commencement we really got to give kudos
the directing and editing of this film
it's like over a freshing fast pace
especially for the kind of comic-book
movie adaptations we get today handheld
but it's done differently like at times
feels like first-person point of view at
times it feels like a video game it
looks cool you could tell what's going
on it kind of riding me like Guy Ritchie
violence in a way all the throwback
vibes to old-school spy movies was great
even if you're not that familiar with
spy movies from back then you will still
get me like the gentleman classy spy it
brought back that British way it brought
back that British charm and their home
from London sweep your chimney on will
all will feel of the small time yeah
these dudes they kick serious ass they
still managed to bring in some like
really cool gadgets you know something
that we don't really get from Bond films
anymore they brought it back it's a
modern-day story but it kind of feels
like a 60s film in a way we really are
in a day and age where comic book movies
are so [ __ ] serious and if there's a
sequel they got an even darker seeing
this movie was like I know it's based on
a comic book but it has more of a comic
book vibe than a lot of movies out there
because it's just so much fun even
though it's not as dark it's like that
rare rr8
comic that's just because it's really
committed to the material in the world
and it's not wasn't a hold back it has
its moments where it takes its time to
be serious but it doesn't stay there for
too long
the fun never truly vanishes Colin Firth
is Harry
this dude stood out to me so much
because he embodies this role embodies
the class he embodies the mentality he
feels like old-school GQ you know even
though he's a serious actor he
understood the style of this film he
understood the humor about the film like
he didn't treat it like it's a comedy
but you could tell he was also having
fun but they're just like just enough
darkness in him to make his performance
just complete Taron Egerton as XD don't
know if i pronounced that right i'm sure
some of you guys have seen this do
before I never have sorry I haven't this
dude he's fantastic
and he's good to look at to my
girlfriend develop such a crush on this
boy during the movie at first I was like
what the [ __ ]
second part of me was like I totally
understand like he's incredibly charming
when he has to do dramatic work he's
really good at the drama it's love this
delivery like every line he does he's
like the master deliverer he probably
had a great Pizza Hut job at one point
it was awesome it was parkour skills you
can tell it's him for the most partner
and the action sequences same goes for
call him first
yeah Deus Ex eating about him two or
three ways soon mark Strong as Merlin
he's like how Q is the James Bond in a
way like he is very like straight for
her performance like dude doesn't really
crack a smile but he's really fun to
watch and there's no denying that he's
also like an intellectual badass and
it's Valentine's Day and funny thing
that's happening right now because
Samuel Jackson plays a guy named
Valentine coincidence no Hollywood knew
what they were doing yes
he's totally having a ball on camera but
he's still not plain samuel l.jackson
like there's an actual character
he doesn't live that makes me found like
this that nothing like him
the most horrible impression of Fatah he
can do and at the end of the day he's
just not your typical villain especially
for a film like this they took that
concept of like a villain who's a you
know a global terrorist threat and will
make some really villainous is his evil
genius but they put such a modern date
touch on that character he's basically
like the Mark Zuckerberg if you went
evil genius this dude is not in this
movie for a lot and I didn't know he was
gonna be in this movie Mark Hamill as
Professor Arnold he doesn't get much
screen time so I want to see too much at
first people sort of laughing his
religious book you Luke Skywalker on
screen but after a while you really do
forget about that it's like hey buying a
mess is character so I'm just getting a
chef that I got I guess if I had to
complain about this film it would be how
some of the female characters are
written like we need more badass women
written more uniquely like we got all
these characters and action films now
but we rarely get that mumma Thurman in
Kill Bill
we're like Natalie Portman and the
professional or like Melissa McCarthy in
the heat like this girl sofia boutella
as his character named gazelle she's
interesting at first because she has you
know blades for feet that was cool and
she you know fights and [ __ ] and that's
cool but in terms of who that character
was there was like nothing really
different about her they got all these
roles that could have all been cliche
and they added a fresh spin on them and
I thought they could have done that with
her other than those minor issues this
film was pretty much what I wanted it to
be and even more it's like when Jesus
turned water into wine but he also had
like cranberry and vodka on the side you
know this looks like what this film did
it was like we got the water of the wine
but Jesus threw in some vodka cranberry
juice may be the coolest bartenders
movie get straight to the point here all
in all I gotta say
Kingsman the Secret Service got it super
bloody right
alright guys thanks for checking on my
review for Kingsman the Secret Service
why don't you go ahead scroll to that
comment box below and tell me is there
some way you think you can track down
where those actor lives so I can make a
agreement with it last but not least
wanting it updated every time one of my
reviews or videos is out the way the
quick room is button by my dig to
subscribe that's right dick let me tell
you something about this little Kingsman
he will give you the secret service if
you pay top dollar you know what I mean
separate himself as a gigolo
thank God chips like this or not in the
Kingsmen movie